nashville would be an example of a city
that is booming
because it is so pro-construction people
are voting with their feet
if you're not going to build housing in
san francisco
i'm going to move to nashville and i
actually am a progressive person for the
most part
but yeah this would be one a b
experiment
where the conservative side has won
almost everyone is moving to
more conservative parts of the country
even if they personally are liberal
because we're building more housing
there the cost of living is lower there
and the taxes are lower there and so
some of that is a race to the bottom
that they want good schools and good
roads without paying the taxes
or they want to start a company in
california and then sell the stock for
it in texas which you can take issue
with
but some of it is about just the fact
that i can
find a home to buy at almost any price
because in nashville
they are building them hand over fist
and so yeah what's the next city after
nashville you think
uh curious atlanta would be another
cities when you go down let me give you
another
a tale of two cities is just seattle and
vancouver so
vancouver is about three hours north of
here it's in canada it does actually
look
a little bit like hong kong it's been
very welcoming to immigrants
and that city has been booming
when there was this huge real estate
crisis in the united states
canada did not have that problem there
were plenty of people who wanted to move
there
prices kept going up but at a reasonable
rate because they have built so much
density
and so if you were to compare seattle to
vancouver
two cities that used to be very similar
there is much more density
um in vancouver and it's an incredible
beautiful walkable city if you're an
urbanist you love vancouver it's
wonderful um i actually went there and i
was just like
transfixed with how vibrant it was i was
like this reminds me of sydney another
high functioning city i love
city by the bay and that is very
interesting the two cities
both of them very liberal and then
during the trump era correct me if i'm
wrong those four years
the united states was blocked off for
indian or asian
immigrants in large part and canada i
had a
in person very high up in the government
say to me j cal
you have people you want for your
startups we'll take them here
we'll give you tax credits and the cost
of living be lower we will get them a
visa in under 10 days
just email us yeah and i was like i've
never gotten that phone call from
trump's office or from biden's office or
obama's previously
i was like canada is aggressive it is a
competition right
now for town oh yeah
well we've had people get stuck on the
wrong side of the border where
you employ a chinese national who goes
back home
and then can't get into the united
states to do his job at redfin
and so we ended up opening an office in
vancouver for that purpose
and i know so many other tech companies
that are doing that so
um i guess there's something for
everyone of every political stripe and
so far there's some liberal policies
that work there's conservative policies
that work i hope you can be ecumenical
about it and really pick the best ideas
regardless of your politics
well i mean it is one of the great
things about you know it's not this
isn't a
this isn't this is a podcast about
innovation and startups
and i think what you're saying is the 50
states in the united states as well as
some
you know next to us like canada uh and
regions
are actually like startups now and
they're innovating and have an offering
for consumers and those consumers are
businesses
and citizens and that means two types of
real estate
i know you don't work in the commercial
real estate space but we have something
like 14
salesforce towers of open office space
in san francisco
what is going to happen in commercial
real estate in a city like san francisco
given that you had massive building
of commercial real estate in san
francisco and at the same time
work from home appeals most of the
companies who were there
and nobody including yourself or myself
wants to live in san francisco i lived
in san francisco i left it wasn't safe
for my family i wanted more space and i
didn't
appreciate that you know the way it was
being run
and so what happens to all that
commercial real estate if you had to
speculate
well first of all i think san francisco
is mostly a safe city
and it's a beautiful city so i left for
my own reasons but
it's not a rejection of the city i do
wish that they had been more aggressive
about
solving the housing crisis by building
more housing
but massive deflation is what's ahead
for commercial real estate because
even if you convert some of those
buildings into condos
the rationale for living downtown was to
be next to
twitter or salesforce or whatever your
employer was
and now when people are working remotely
i don't think they necessarily want to
live downtown as much so
just looking at the housing market the
housing market for single family homes
as you had already observed
has been red hot the housing market for
condos
has been less so some of that is about
sharing a
air conditioning or heating system with
other people
but mostly it's just about the fact that
people have wanted more space
so i don't think that converting
commercial real estate
into residential is going to solve
many problems i actually
my kid is on a soccer team with another
kid whose parent
holds the owns the building that redfin
leases
and he was telling me that i know y'all
are coming back commercials going to be
back bigger than ever
that's just watching the game
okay fella that's optimistic
i mean yeah being delusional part of
being a great entrepreneur isn't it like
you have to be a little delusional
but that's straight up delusional the
idea that
tech companies are going to be able to
take people who have left and
relocated like you said to a bigger
space and who are working from home
i mean that's just farcical that that
will happen in our lifetimes i think
yeah i mean almost every ceo right now
is comparing the length of their leases
because we're all trying to figure out
when we can get out yeah oh you just
signed a 10-year lease in 2019.
oh man what are you going to do about
that then somebody else would say i
signed a 10-year lease in
2011. and so it came to it the perfect
time
and if you look at the companies yeah
yeah well
we sort of went through peak office in
2020 or 2021
early 2021 where facebook and google
weren't just doing the sushi chef
and the little ball thing that you jump
into but they were also thinking about
building housing for their employees
next to the campus and apple broke
ground and salesforce had this big tower
and it was just peak office and now the
companies that were most militant
about asking people to come back are the
ones
that had the biggest edifice complex the
ones
who had either built their own space or
signed a very long lease
or you know did something that was sort
of an ego trip
uh kind of landscape architecture and
crazy building architecture and
and it just seems a little silly now and
so
um turns out people work well remotely
as you've probably already established
on this show
healthy and happy employees create
successful companies and that's
a fact com for business can help your
employees be their best selves at work
partner with the number one mental
fitness app provides support and tools
for all of your employees
com can help kick-start mental
well-being initiatives by
empowering employees to stress less and
to rest better
and build their resilience com has an
entire library of content specifically
designed
for the workplace and it includes lo-fi
music playlists so you can get in that
flow state quick
breathing breaks guided meditations and
hundreds
of soothing sleep stories so that your
team gets a great night's sleep and they
come back the next day
ready to take on the world they even
have programs tailored for mental health
and productivity like their mindfulness
at work series
millions of employees at over 600
companies like lincoln
iterable and universal studios use com
for business i have been a com user and
i was an investor in the company luckily
it's such a great company it works so
well and
i'm so proud of them that they have this
business product now because a lot of my
employees are under a lot of stress not
just because they work for me
but working from home all the things
going on in the world you need a little
equanimity and the way you're going to
get that is with com for business so get
in there folks
com is offering a free well-being ebook
for hr and benefit leaders and one month
free
after you attend a free demo at com.com
twist that's right a free ebook and one
month free
after just attending a simple demo at
com.com
twist once again calm.com
twist